welcome to the recruitment mentors
podcast my name is hisham azuz
today i'm delighted to be joined by tom
ponting
who is the founder of amber resourcing
who are
a tech specialist recruitment agency tom
started his recruitment career in 2006
working in finance recruitment but then
joined a 10 person
it team at opus recruitment in 2010
where he progressed through the ranks
from consultant all the way to regional
and managing director
where he was then responsible for a
business unit generating around 30
million
in turnover before he then left
opus to start amber resourcing in 2019
um in this time he's been back to scale
and grow
amber resourcing they currently have 11
people in the business but have
ambitious plans
to grow the business across the uk
and look to get to the 60 90 people uh
mark over the next three years
so tom thank you for joining me oh thank
you thank you for the lovely intro as
well mate
nice so where i always like to start and
the first question i have for you tom
is in your opinion what characteristics
and traits do you think make up a highly
successful recruitment consultant
yeah okay so i think it's not really
a trait if you like or characterize it
but it's um
the the first thing for me is like hard
work and
bring it right back to the the basics of
the best people
that i've worked with um within the
first six months of joining the business
have
probably been the people that have put
in the most amount of effort and
it's like it's a really like easy core
thing that anyone can really do
but the people that tend to put the most
amount of effort
hit the kpis early doors that that they
they seem to be
the people that that work out the best
um so
hard work being one of them resilience
is another one um
i'd say to anyone that's joining or
looking to get into recruitment the
first six months
that i mean that there'll definitely be
tears at some point or another if there
aren't tears you're probably not pushing
yourself hard enough
um and and to the resilience of
being in a position where like you're
just not letting things
affect you for more than a day the the
rule i have is like yeah if
something goes wrong like let it affect
you like
let it hurt a little but when you come
in the next day make sure
yeah make sure you leave that the door
and you come in it's a fresh day and
we're kind of going again so that's like
that's the kind of two kind of cool ones
consistency
is what makes what takes good bills to
great bidders
and these are the guys that and girls
that that get to a position where
you know the consistency of the bad
months uh
they're still still sticking in a deal
or two um
and then obviously the good lumps are
more so consistency is another one and
i also think the ability to actually
listen
and and take a step back and understand
something
um i think listening is such a
underrated
um underrated skill to have as a as a
recruit or not underrated but underused
if you like
so just just before we carry this on i
love the
fact that you brought up consistency
just keen to to sort of zoom in on that
quickly
because i think everyone listened to
this wants to be more consistent
right i guess look you would you would
you would have seen
so many recruiters in your time yeah
so i guess when when i say to you a
great consistent biller what i what are
the sort of top three things you think
that they
sort of do day in day out week out that
maybe
some people don't do that could prevent
them being consistent
yeah okay well speaking from experience
the
when i say consistency it's coming in
and doing the same access it's like it's
again it sounds really
like simple and easy but so many times
i've been
with consultants where they've had a
superb month they've got this massive
commit commission check at the end of
the month
and the next month they're just not the
races they're the
they're doing whatever they whatever
they're doing with their money but
they're not coming back and not
following the same actions
i think a lot of recruitment is quite
like mathematical in terms of the
numbers and
what you have to do to achieve the end
result being at two
three four whatever deals per month so
the consistency is actually the actual
the actual um work you put in um
throughout the course and i said the
inputs um if you do the same amount of
inputs
on most months the outputs will be
what the inputs dictated so that that's
what i mean by consistency
is actually some some consultants will
have one month
and um they'll be superb and uh
they'll get the big commission check
that they'll do 30 40 50k
whiteboard and then they'll go off the
boil and you'll see the game in in two
or three months time
so just having that level consistent
input would be
yeah would be uh would be the focus yeah
so yeah so i think you're talking about
getting complacent there as well and i
think
i think the other thing that you're
talking about there which i think is
really interesting is because straight
away we're now talking about
just just uh it's come up a few times
now but just a word that
people for whatever reason have
tarnished which is kpis right
but it's what you said it's actually
well no it's actually
understanding the science behind what
you need to do
that will give you the best chance of
achieving the outcomes that you need
so i think that i'm glad you highlighted
that because i think i think that's the
way it needs to be
sort of positioned isn't it it's like
well okay so you've done 50 grand this
month
like let's have a look do you understand
why you was able to do that
like yes you are good and you have
talent and these things but do you
actually know why you think you was able
to achieve that and i think that's what
you're talking to isn't it
the best recruiters understand the
science that they need to
sort of put in each month that can give
them the best chance
yeah i think when people mention kpis
they kind of crease up a little like oh
my god kpis
um but what do you actually break it
down it would use like you said i'm such
a positive
a positive angle say okay well how have
you done this 50k
what would they want you to do that and
you track it back and you look at the
kpis and you go okay well that's
if you want to do 50k again here's your
platform to
to do it and if you haven't done it then
we need to maybe inspect the quality in
which you're doing it at
so yeah i think i mean going back to
starting up and
doing this with amber and starting doing
billing myself it's like i needed kpis i
needed to know what
what i needed to do in order to get my
two or three deals for the course of the
month so
yeah i think kpis are really underrated
in terms of i think again
people crease up a little bit and get
nervous and scared of a kpi but it's um
it should be a recruiter's best friend
[Music]
yeah yeah absolutely i think yeah if
you're if you're listening to this
straight away it's like
let make sure you look to look this
quarter last quarter last month like
you should be able to answer the
question with your manager with yourself
right okay how did i achieve that what
are some of the cool things i need to do
and
i think that's what you've highlighted
quite quickly so amazing so how
just to frame this up for people so
obviously for the last
coming tours 18 months you've been a
recruitment business owner right of
amber
i'm resourcing so obviously slightly
different journey there but and then
obviously um before that you was an
employee but obviously got to the
position where you're managing pnls
teams etc
so we're going to start there and sort
of break some of that down and then
we'll go into
tom the business owner so i guess how
would you
and phil just whatever comes up for you
naturally but like
how would you describe like your sort of
early on in recruitment for you
how would you describe it i'm always
interested yeah um
i i just i absolutely love that i think
i'm one of those people
that i think a lot of people fall into
recruitment don't they yeah yeah
whereas as soon as i i got a kind of an
understanding of what recruitment was i
i always
wanted to get into recruitment it was
like it was my dream job
uh using the insurance was using
insurance sales or something
yeah same yeah yeah so i actually um
i first got wind of it when i used to
play for a football team and um
and one of the guys has a guy called
nigel romano who
um is one of the senior people at opus
and we're in the change room he said
listen i think you'll be quite good at
recruitment because
you know your attitude and your ability
to communicate and whatnot
um and i looked a little bit further
into it i actually i actually dropped
out of college and
back in those days and those things are
so really old
but back in those days it was a case of
you you
usually had to be a graduate to get a
chance at some of these
it was a little bit tougher to get into
um
so i seek some advice and i said we'll
get some sales experience behind you
yeah and and you know
with some sales experience over a
prolonged period of time and you've got
you know much better chance so
yeah that's what i did uh when i did a
few years in insurance sales
and then uh got an opportunity to to
come out to bristol
and uh an interview for a recruiting
business but yeah i i honestly think i
was born and made for this
yeah 100 i can't i can't think of myself
doing anything else
so it's uh so
first few years then obviously you
obviously clearly had the passion for it
but
were they rocky were they good did you
was it a doctor what
how would you describe it like like a
doctor walter okay i'm
taking it back to the kpis i like i'm
i'm quite a simplistic man he's like
you tell me what needs to be done and
i'll do it and i sat down on my first
job and
they said well hit these figures and do
these numbers and you'll do x and i just
just did exactly that but i stuck my
head down and
and i did the numbers and i did the
numbers probably and 50
more and lo and behold you know within
in my first position i was you know the
top really there for
for two and a half three years and then
you know the call-up um came when i went
to oprah's and exactly the same thing
happened there so
yeah there was there was no kind of
rocky rocky moments at all because
again i followed the process that
someone gave me i followed
their instructions and the numbers that
they said
i needed to hear okay so let's just
hone in a bit on the sort of opus
journey then
um so obviously from what i can see
which i think is interesting and you may
speak to recruiters
now doing this to be fair or you may
have at some point in your career but
obviously i saw that you had to
transition from finance to tech
right so i think sometimes recruiters
listening to this may go through that or
could be quite worried about that
so i guess so looking back at that
i guess did you find anything difficult
about transitioning
into a different sector what did you do
to give yourself the best chance of
having a good start i don't know how
would you describe that change and what
would your advice be for someone that
would be transitioning first of all i
must admit that that was my biggest
reservation i was [ __ ] scared i was like
yeah come from a finance background
where it's it's not fairly easy but but
it was fairly easy because i've been
doing for two and a half years right
and that was my biggest reservation and
i actually met with darren the owner a
few times
um and i because of most of my friends
were working there
um at the time and i was like okay well
i'm not i'm just i'm not very technical
and and i'm not sure if this really
excites me and it didn't really at the
time
um and well you know you pick it up it's
sales and sales recruitment recruitment
if you can recruit and you're successful
in one area
you can probably do in most areas you
just need to invest a bit of time
learning the market so that was that
that was the first thing and i think
yeah the the first few months um
you you just started speaking to candice
to to really gather a better
understanding of the market but i think
you probably
you you you probably get away every bit
by by using a few bit buzzwords
in the first few months and and winging
it a little bit
um but yeah that was the biggest
reservation
but it that came quite quickly i think
within i was i will say if the people
are joining it give yourself three
months
and if every single day you're learning
more than the day before
it's a progression as you're moving the
right the
area so it probably took about two or
three months to be to get up to speed
with some of the lingo
but again i think you're always learning
so i'm still learning stuff now right
yeah i think i think the especially in
tech what i find when i
speak to recruiters or sort of work
recruiters and stuff is like there's
this sort of
misconception that like you have to know
as much as the people
as you place or be as competent as them
but you're never going to be as
competent as them i know
it looks like a quite interesting usp
where some recruitment business is going
down the route of like all of our
recruiters learn to code and stuff like
that right and fair enough but i think
like you're i think the actual real
value that you offer what you're talking
about there is actually
the insight and you're speaking to way
more people like that candidate who may
speak to a handful of people
a lot more per week than you are than
than them so
actually the value that recruiters will
always have is that well look you're the
fifth person i spoke to in the same
position
this is what i found out so far blah
blah blah i think it seems like i feel
like that's a common misconception in
texas oh
i don't know i don't know anything i'm
not a techie but it's like well you
don't get paid
to be a techie you you get paid to have
that insight and
all those things you know yeah i'd much
rather a
consultant that knew everything about a
company and
and from the company size to the
progression of the company to
to everything in between right i'd much
rather that than someone would be
actually technically
um apt enable um and with that
information then they can obviously
relay that to the cans they speak to
and then hopefully the cell is actually
in the detail
that they give the candidate from the
knowledge of the company
yeah yeah exactly so i i just find that
sort of an interesting
nuance which sometimes people um get
worried about but
thank you for sharing that so i guess a
couple of things i want to ask you then
before we go into
this sort of amber journey so obviously
opus is
big brand um well known brand in the
industry
so i guess you said you had a couple of
mates there but how would you
sort of describe the dna of sort of opus
and the dna of their culture that you
think
helped it or contributed it to become
sort of a big brand as it has
yeah okay so so so the
it was listed of like quality quality
consultants
which is which is one of the things i
think you know the likes of
uh christina massa too and ryan speeds
and mojo romana and i could go on and on
with a list of people that
just fantastic zeph um khatira so
it had some some superb people within
the business
but the the dna was just kind of go
harder and faster than
anyone else um in the early days
it kind of felt like we were we were
kind of taking on the world
um and this is when i joined with 10
people be
just based in in bristol um
and and as the as the company grew we
just managed to attract some some
fantastic talent so the actual
atmosphere the environment was you know
you give us this job
um and you put us against any other
recruitment consultancy in the lands and
we'll beat you that was the the the kind
of vibe we had within the office and
usually it kind of usually worked out
that that was the case because we would
go harder and faster and we would work
longer
um so that was the the the kind of the
coupled with that
um particularly from an early stage we
had um
we had like a brilliant training
offering i think the
the trainer was like employee number six
within a business which
usually doesn't like happen like that
does it yeah you get to a certain size
or you
outsource the training but the the
trainer was um
was a lady called louise foster and she
was just superb
um and uh yeah the training and
the development of people um within the
business even that small was uh was
superb so why did why so why did you
highlight that then was that because it
then meant that there was
less people getting sort of chewed up
and spat back out
like you reduced retention did it mean
that from like very early on actually
the
which typically doesn't happen early on
there was actually an opus way of doing
things or there was a process that
a framework and um a yes a playbook for
people to follow what
why do you highlight that because i
think it's interesting yeah i think i
think 100
is the it's the playbook it's the
blueprint right if you find out
what makes a successful consultant yeah
um and then you have that trainer that's
um
that's that's developing you on a on a
consistent basis
um uh yeah that does seem to be the main
thing so
that was that for me from my early days
particularly there where i'd probably
come from
um a business where i might have a
training day every
kind of four months or so to have a
constant training constant feedback
constant development that was probably
the the the key
for my growth and development and i know
a lot of lots of others as well
so just a quick one on this because i
think this is interesting and and
we can maybe touch on this when we talk
about
how you've maybe tried to replicate this
but i guess for people
listening to this not everyone's going
to have the luxury of having someone
dedicated
to l d and get so i guess i don't know
like what would your advice be for
recruiters listen to this that do have
that hunger and desire to want to
improve and it's likely that they do if
they're listening to this and
how would you encourage them to try and
get that feedback or try and get those
opportunities where they can improve
despite maybe not having what you just
described earlier on the opus
well i mean it's something that i'm
actually searching for myself is in
terms of like having a training offering
where society
needs to be the right person for sure
but um
i i think it's it's i think some
companies and i'm talking
about business owners might see training
and
and development as a as a as money down
the drain
um but in terms of what it can return
you
it's obviously not right um so
yeah i think it's just in terms of the
investment of making sure that that that
these guys are developing um that seems
to be
that that's that that's that's the
biggest thing and that's something i'm
also looking to replicate now
now i'm on the i'm out there talking to
to people about
you know bringing a full-time trade
trainer into the business so that that's
a
that's a big thing for me now still as
well okay
interesting so um what i wanted to just
ask you then was obviously a lot of
recruiters want to
sort of get to the position that you got
to which was sort of progressed all the
way to sort of director level
and as you quite rightly said there was
a lot of great people in that business
so there would have been a lot of people
that
i guess would have wanted the position
that you was going for the promotion
that he was after so
again something i'm always curious about
is in an extremely competitive landscape
not just externally but internally as
well with your peers
why do you think tom was able to get the
promotions
that you got over the person sitting
next to you
well i i must admit some of the
promotions
were because we were we were growing at
such a rapid rate i was kind of almost
thrust into those positions because
there was probably
no one better at the time and truth be
told
i probably wasn't ready for a lot of
them um and
yeah they did it's yeah we moved so
quickly we we grew at such a rate um
that you know before i knew i was
running a team of 260 come the end
um so what what why
why did they think of tom because i
think what what's come up a few times i
understand that but i guess surely you
must have communicated at some point
like that you or someone that would put
your hand up if that did i don't know
yeah no it definitely is it definitely
said there was an opportunity that that
that
and i always like to be i always like to
put myself out my
my comfort zone if i ever if i ever feel
comfortable and i'm like
i don't like this i need to i need to be
pushing again so
i think every single time there was an
opportunity
i put my hand up i wouldn't always get
the opportunity but the opportunity
i got the opportunity eventually right
um so it is a case of putting your hand
up and saying yeah
give me some more responsibility i feel
like i'm in the position where
i can again put myself out the comfort
zone a little
okay interesting so just for contacting
and then we'll
take this into this sort of journey as a
business owner so
by the time you left you said you was
managing a team of 60 did you say
yeah yeah yeah 60 people and that's a
permanent contract and a delivery team
yeah okay um so i'm assuming it sort of
grew to that but i guess what
against what people want to know and i'm
sure you'll know is that
yeah a lot of recruiters will be
thrusted into leadership positions and
quite quite a lot of the time haven't
been given any leadership training
um and have to sort of work out the hard
way how to get the best out of their
team
um which can then lead to sometimes
people saying that they've got managers
that micromanage them and all those
things so i guess
looking back on your leadership journey
there yeah
i guess sort of thinking about people
listening to this that might end up
going on that journey what would your
advice be
for them that maybe you had to learn the
hard way for people
going on that leadership journey yeah of
course i mean i
put my hands up i think i was a terrible
manager for the first few years
why let's talk about that because you've
kept it really positive why
why do you think it wasn't that great
potentially
i don't like to to blame things i don't
like to blame things or people but maybe
i was
like like a product of the environment a
little bit and maybe
it's how i was managed or um
maybe it was just a case of i just i
just wasn't very good my
my emotional intelligence wasn't superb
um
i expected more of people than they
probably expected of themselves
um i think a lot of the time i was
judging people to my standards
so i i i've never ever asked anyone to
do something that i wouldn't do
ever yeah just i would i wouldn't do it
and that's still the case now um
but but you know it's a case of if
you're not doing these
at the time you're not doing these stats
and there's these inputs and i
am still running a team with 20s like
what are you doing
if you're not doing these speakers and
i'm running a team of 20 and doing it's
like come on it's like
for me to do this and do the job at a
much better rate than you
it's like come on that that's how that
was that was how it was
um and again as i said i think i think
for
probably the good the first like three
or four years of management obviously i
think i was
i was awful um
what do you have to change then so you
had to not measure people
how you would yourself it seemed like
one
again going back to the training we
actually had some um some management
training we had a lot of emotional
intelligence training which which helped
me that went
um and i think i just kind of mellowed
out as a person a little bit as well
right over the years so just as i got a
little bit older i was like well
you know like if they don't do a 100
phone calls or send out
15 cvs or whatever it's like you know
that's that's up to them so if they want
to be successful and
follow the that's given to them they
can't do so but
you know if they don't want to do that
and they still want to knock in 10k a
month doing it their way then and so be
it
let's embrace that and let's help them
do it that way
but again that came with that
okay interesting so let's let's sort of
take this into
you starting amber then um
so obviously started in 2019 i guess
what what i i'm always interested in a
lot of people
may say down the pub or wherever like
someday i'm going to start my own
recruitment business
i think a lot of people aspire to that
like what
what gave you the confidence to sort of
take that first step
yeah well i've actually i've actually
like threatened to do it before i'd
been in a position a couple of times
where um what i handed my notice in a
few years before
um and didn't quite follow through of it
um
took a counteroffer yeah
yeah you could say that there was there
was a little bit more to it
but there was a little more to it um
which was looking back at the time i
probably wasn't quite ready
um right and i was i was decent on the
billing side and running a team by that
by that time but in terms of the other
stuff
the the the running the business side um
i had i was completely clueless so
um yeah so what was your question
again so basically i was just interested
like a lot of people have the idea
or the aspirations to start a business
but how not many people take that first
step you know we'll talk i know yeah
we're going to talk about
you being sort of invested to start and
stuff but i guess
that could be part of it but what yeah i
don't know what
how did you take that first step yeah
and then it was because i was there for
nearly 10 years i was
like it's kind of all right we'll ever
know or new
and um actually the process
happened over probably like a six month
period for me
um so it wasn't like a snap decision
right let's go
i started thinking about it i knew i
always wanted to do it at some point and
i knew
um that that that day it would come a
day when i
had to do it so i started thinking about
it and actually was quite vocal
about i actually went to my manager to
listen this is
this is my situation this is how i'm
feeling at the moment
um you know we've had a good great year
last year
and i'm in the position where i think
it's time now where
um i i need to spread my wings and
then stop and start my own business so i
was like quite vocal about
the whole scenario and then a couple of
months went by and it just felt more and
more
like the time was right um
yeah so so it was it was yeah it was a
it was a slower process like a drip feed
of like
over six months and just go yes so i was
like right now i'm
definitely completely but there's a few
things that were happening that wasn't
you know i didn't really
agree with that much but that's you know
that's that's beyond my control
i'm now ready to make a decision that
you know let's let's have a look
and see what's uh see what's wrong okay
so just to be clear then because i know
you spoke about this before so obviously
before you then took the leap
you had been you hadn't been on the
tools for how long
well yeah probably probably been about
two or three years
um yes i might you know do the the odd
clothes in the office like at the
hollywood club oh
there he is yeah at uh the working
yeah so so obviously you've been um
and it'd be great just to start here so
you you've obviously got a relationship
with an investor that's
that's helped you supported you start
amber yeah
yeah so could you just talk a bit about
that i guess one how did you meet this
investor
yeah and um how does it actually work i
think
as i shared with you before we went on
to this i think a lot of people
always i don't know i feel like from the
conversation i have just have a quite
sort of negative view of
if i if i go with an investor i'll go
with someone that's going to support me
start my recruitment business aren't
they going to take all my money
um so yeah how did you how did you meet
your investor
and sort of how have you how does it
actually work and then we'll talk about
the journey so far
yeah well first of all um i i'm kind of
in a position where i've got
three kids and um
an expensive wife and and i
i was kind of living to my means and i
didn't have many savings because
we're just because i'm a recruit
consultant and some of us don't right
so i need to find someone that could
help support me because i need to have
an income
like a basic income that is x amount so
that was like one of my first things
like i want to go and do it
but i don't have the ability means
backing
family connections whatever you want to
call it to be able to do it from scratch
from myself
um so so when i was out talking to to
other people i also checked around the
market and i saw other people set up and
i was like okay well
that person seemed to have set up and
then investor looks good so
when i started looking it was actually
for a rec to wreck um
funny enough and uh he put me in touch
with
a few different investors and i also
wanted to i
also wanted an investor that could
um like lead me to my own devices a
little bit and i was prepared to back me
when
when you know i'm not really asking any
questions
um so that again i had probably asking
for the world was asking for a
like a decent base salary that i could
take
within the position i was asking for a
decent percentage
um and then maybe um maybe a company
that could offer me the
the ability to to bring a few people
into the business pretty quickly
um so that that that was why
that that was that was the situation so
i went on to to a few people in bristol
and had conversations
um then when i stumbled upon uh
the the investor i had now and i sat
down with him and i said well this is
what
this is what i'm after these are not my
demands but
these are the things that i'm really
looking for and support and help from uh
from investor and ended up to where i am
now
amazing and would you mind look you
don't have to go into the exact details
but i think it's just good context for
people so
i think what i took from that is he was
really honest with yourself the fact
that
your circumstances and stuff will
actually look i'm not going to be bitter
about this i actually
it's actually the the best option
possible for me to start a recruitment
business is
having someone having something involved
and then it seemed like you
quite quickly worked out what you wanted
that relationship to look like
in terms of you wanted the autonomy you
wanted to yeah you know
you knew what you wanted right um so i
guess the just the final context
initiative i think is useful
is like yeah how how does it sort of
simply work than in terms of
you owning um the the business how does
that work and
how just how does that relationship work
if you wouldn't mind sharing no of
course
so i started off with a percentage um
with with the invest in it and it wasn't
really like a big negotiation it was
actually i thought i thought like
extremely fast like okay well here's
your percentage
yeah and your percentage grows to 50
after you hit
uh two milestone targets the two
milestone targets are
you know money kept within the business
so nothing else no no retention
no no headphone growth no nothing is
like you hit these two sides of cash
within the business
then you get your two kickers and two
that's what
when you get to 50 um it will be you'll
be in a position then
where um if you wanted to in the future
take more from us
you can we'll talk about a buyout for
further percentage but on the flip side
what we'll offer you
is um a free office for a period of time
um we'll offer you some support and
money to to
for yourself and to bring other people
into the business
um and we'll also obviously
offer offer you there's like 12 months
of like free
back-end support operational support um
from the finance team the hr team the
legal team
which we which we needed the first the
first few months
looking at the deal in terms of the what
was on offer and what they gave to me
um these are the things that i was
nervous about
um that i probably really needed like
just little things like
doing terms or yeah responding to a
legal letter or
um finance or contract to finance all
these all this kind of stuff and they
said well we'll we'll sort all of that
for you within the deal for the first 12
months so
yeah that was the uh that was that was
the deal
now thank you for that and i think what
i think what's great about that it seems
like
it's just it's super simple um and
not complicated like there isn't these
like weird loopholes that you have to
get at nfi to x amount and all these
things so i guess
final thing on this then like how so
what would you say have been
one like what has actually so you've
spoken about what you wanted it to be
like you explained the
some of the real positives what has the
actual experience been like so far
like you shared what you wanted to be
like what has actually been like and
then two
what would you say so far have been the
sort of most positive impacts
in actually going down that path to
start your own recruitment business and
grow your own recruitment business
yeah so so first first of all it's been
it's been it's been really exciting i
feel like
i'm not too cheesy like reborn again but
i kind of do feel like that a little bit
i felt like i've
i've got my got my heads back not i
think i may have lost it but it's just
in a different way
yeah um so the it's yeah it's been an
incredibly exciting journey that
to get back into a position where
you're actually recruiting i've always
loved
um to recruit um it's it's it's always
got to be extremely excited about having
a project and be able to fill that
project
yeah um so actually going back to to
recruiting
was was was superb um
and then i had and even though we came
for a recession so we actually didn't
get our team back fully up and running
until
uh january and then come march
coronavirus here so we actually
really had one like decent month of
recruitment
um of of of free generation if you like
in the february
uh before march came and and obviously
that there wasn't much to be done
between march and
probably june right and again going back
to
picking the right investor what we're
talking about before
is you know we were we were funding like
six people's
six decent people's salaries um
and there was there was never a question
not not once was
did the investor come knocking and
saying what you know what we're doing
about this
there was always confidence that you'd
get would get back to the position where
we'd go okay well we're back here now
let's let's just make sure we go harder
and faster than
than that than we did before then so
yeah in terms of that
the positive stuff oh there's been
there's been so many like different
positive wins that we've had um since
we've been kind of back from
like i'd say i think it's like june of
june this or juno
junior yes um
we've grown for a pandemic um we've had
some
superb talent um in terms
of why why i was looking to come close
to this
investor he owns a company called
sanderson's
and they were delivery focused on
delivery model business
um where my whole career had been spot
business um
i think in one year i did like 50 odd
deals within a year and
and there was 48 different clients so
proper spot business which i knew was a
limiting factor for my
for my personal development so i wanted
to align myself with a business where
they did
completely the opposite um and they got
in
got him with with a few clients and
landed and expanded and developed those
those are camps out so it was really
good to come into that environment
and also like almost like learn a
different way to recruit
yeah to provide a superb service over a
long
period of time so yeah that that's
probably the the biggest wins we've got
some superb plans we've
done incredibly well um we've grown as a
business and
you know the future's looking good at
the moment so how um
just just it helps with context and then
we'll sort of break this down
a bit before we finish what how how did
you do revenue wise first year
gross profit wise first year then yeah
well revenue-wise
gross profit for the first year runs
from
july to june we were down 100 we're down
100k
within within the first 12 months and
obviously that was towards
the end of the lockdown so we've really
really been going for
um outside of a lockdown if you like
being
in for a cup for a couple of months um
and then
um since we've come back um from from
that
um the gp has been like close to like
uh 700 000 um from
uh from june um you know we're
we're averaging um like 100k months
um with a team of well we watched the
startup it was
like five pillars and we've grown to to
a level in total so
yes it was uh we've we've kind of come
through that 100k down
and more up so we've had a really good
run of things
amazing great work so i guess couple of
things i'm keen to
unpack here then before we finish so
i guess firstly
i guess firstly because i think a lot of
people think about this
like when you thought about when you
started forming
the plan for amber and these things like
did you spend much time thinking about
your usp or like i don't know what was
your differentiator
no do you know what that's something i'm
struggling with still now really
i'll put my hands up yeah i i know what
i don't we're good at but
i i don't i also don't want to feel like
a phony and
and give a story which i don't fully
commit or believe
yeah yeah i think everyone's everyone's
looking for an angle at the moment and
they say you know we do this and we do
that and we sponsor this it's like
all very good causes i'm sure but but i
want to
i want to i want to be able to to be in
a position where i go okay well
here's here's what we do here's what
we're good at and this is our usp
um you know the the the usps i'm going
to say are going to be the same as what
everyone says we do we're just
we're vertical market market specialists
the people i have within the business
are just they're just the best of what
they do
and we have really really tight patches
in terms of the tech we use but
that's the same as everyone yeah yeah
yeah i
appreciate i appreciate the honesty um
because i think a lot of people
especially
on the journey there that i think they
can spend a lot of time thinking about
what that unique thing is but i think at
the same time yeah i respect that you're
still working that out but
you you do know what you can do really
well which is the inch wild mould deep
and get some really good people that
know their patch i guess
the thing that i wanted to ask you then
next was a close second was like
the most the sort of always the
challenge in recruitment business that
want to grow is hiring people for their
own business
right which again i always say is the
most ironic thing right so
like you've got some great people on the
bus
and it seems quite good i always see the
pictures of you guys with
i don't know transfer deadline day like
a bottle of champagne or whatever you
know what i mean so
it always seems like you guys are on on
the positive mark so i guess
what do you think and this could be very
reliant on you whatever but whatever
comes up for you like what do you think
you've done well
to get people on the bus considering
you know how many recruitment businesses
you guys could join the aren't yours
yeah well i i think first of all i've
got i've got a superb team that really
helps right
um in terms of the the the characters we
have on the team
in terms of of um how they are as people
that
that just the brilliant bunch of people
which i think always helps when a person
comes in for an interview and a chat and
and that they're dealing with good
people that are doing well and happy
and enjoy their job that that's always
always a thing
i've always think that um that actually
like
internal recruitment has been has been
my strong point
um it's something that that uh
to grow opus the way we growed it uh
grew it
um i was just yeah i i just i
probably spent about fifty percent of my
time out there talking to people
understanding the market market
mapping knowing who's good um and
then i'd imagine um you know through by
from my experience um i'd like to think
that i've developed some people along
the way and you'd also like to think
that you know bristol is quite a small
place then
people start to talk and all of a sudden
it's like you probably get a bit of a
reputation for
for someone that's that's done good
within the business and and that also
helps as well right
um so yeah i think um i think the
the key thing is is making sure that the
people i have of the in the business are
are enjoying it and they're having fun
and um
when they sit down and speak to people
um in terms of in terms of interviews
they're giving a
good um a good account of where we're
going as a as a company
so you so you just well i guess what i'm
interested in and you just said that
it's probably one of those strong points
of
speaking to people and trying to equip
these things so i guess you just shared
with us that
you are definitely still working out
your usp and these things so i guess
what i'm just interested in curious on
is like what were you selling to these
people what was it that
yes you've got you may have developed
these people in the past but i guess i'm
just interested in like
what was the cell what did you get these
people bought in to
yeah yeah so so first of all um
when i first came that the first few
people were known to me that
that so i think in like first hand
um if they were looking to leave the
business i had a presentation
on a laptop and i think i probably spent
the first month just presenting this
presentation of you know what we're
doing and where we're looking to go
yeah um so so that probably helped i
knew a lot of their motivations a lot of
their drivers um
and i could i could i could paint the
picture where they were going to go as
an individual within the business so
that probably helped
um in terms of the other people i think
it's just a lot of honesty
um yeah i think if you call a spade a
spade i think
i think people um that they know when
someone's bullshitting
and they can see right through you so if
you're not good at something or you
think there's a weakness or you think
there's something that needs to be
improved
you've got to tell them um but you've
also got to tell them what you're going
to do about
changing it and making it making it make
it good for example
um so that i think that's also helped me
um
painting the picture of where i'd like
to be as a as a as a business and also
the mentorship and the development
they're going to get from from me and
the other people within the
office as well okay and then
the other thing that i want to just just
because you would have done a lot of
this i'm assuming
opus and now as you continue to do it to
gramble but like
people want to know like what so it
seems like have you typically in
amber have you hired experienced people
uh i i make a mix of the two um
okay you know a mix of the two and okay
i've uh
one of my highs one of my first tires
was i've got
a static caravan done at devon cliffs um
and and he sold me the caravan i was
like was like mate
you're not too bad at this you ever
thought about coming into recruitment
i've thought about i said well get
yourself up here and then we'll uh we'll
have an interview and
get you through the door so it's like
spotting potential in in people that
just don't have recruited recruitment
experience so
there's a mix between experience and
non-experience fair the
the reason why i ask because people want
to know tom and
people want to note on basically like
what is it that you actually personally
look for in the new hire and
not not the sort of high level classic
like hard-working all that stuff i guess
what has been typically the sort of
secret source that you've
looked for in people that yeah has ended
up working out what is it that you
truly actually look for in people like
honestly
someone that can give me six months is
usually
is usually the the key thing if i like
it i think with most people
um if you give me six months of your of
of your time
um i'll be able to turn them into a
consistent performing
uh biller so so that's like the key
things
are they are they gonna run the first
sign of trouble
um are they gonna be in a position where
things don't go quite their way over a
month period and they don't do a deal or
they have a drop out
they're gonna they're gonna leave and go
somewhere else that that's the that's
the key thing for me so
yeah the the six months give me six
months with your of your
like professional life um and i think i
can i can turn you into a but
that's the usual thing that runs from my
head and also like are they a nice
person and all that kind of stuff
um but that's that's the key one for me
yeah fair
and then look and you're in you we we
always speak a lot about getting new
people but
don't always tend to speak about keeping
people i guess in your
sort of journey so far what what things
of you may be opus or what you continue
to do
amber like what sort of things do you
really try and do as a leader or put in
place to
to keep your best people from leaving
and
yeah i mean there's a lot of things i'd
like to
do more outside of obviously having
coronavirus but in terms of what we've
done so far
it's we've we've had um a trainer coming
to
to to do extra trading and development
sessions
um giving people more responsibility
of taking on um that that next step of
their career
um and lots of like fun stuff outside of
work again
outside of chronovirus but just makes
making sure that they're enjoying
themselves having a
having a good time because it can be it
can be the hardest job in the world
sometimes and particularly i think that
kind of
team leads uh principal consultant to
team lead role where you're just taking
on a whole new
skill set uh just making sure that
they're having as much fun as they
possibly can
yeah fair enough so i guess i
just feel like you're being like really
positive
you're obviously someone that's got a
really positive mindset which i actually
love
yeah you you do struggle to find me in a
in a
on that neck i think that's again one of
the things you know what i said to you
about having
having that having that attitude of like
leaving at the door if you have a bad
day yeah of course
yeah yeah i've had some i've had some
terrible days
um but you can't you just can't never
hold you but
with the recruitment concerns it's a bad
day that you know as
a recruiter someone leaves your business
or someone doesn't take your offer or
someone drops out right
yeah it's like no one's dying we're not
we're not we're not surgeons
it's not perspective it's perspective
isn't it it's like crisis like
you know i was an insurance broker for
three years so what i mean it's like you
know i had to read off a script i'm now
in a position oh my god that was great
it was horrible so yeah yeah the yeah
the the reason why is because like
people always message me and people want
to know like tom what was your
what were your darkest days what were
like what were the biggest lumps that
you had that
that you got through and how you got
through it it seems like you've really
honed that muscle of like
today's a new day perspective yeah i
don't know i'm sure you've had to help
people get through that
i think yeah i've had i've had some some
really bad days i've had like
bad days when people have had
you know really really bad news and
um and it's kind of like processing and
dealing that with them together as a
as a as a couple so i've had
we had a commission change at the last
gaff and
it was a terrible day for me because i
was looking at i was going
how can i put a spin on this it's like
how can i
how can i sell this because i'd like i
like to you know
usually with a commission you can go
actually okay we're changing it here but
here's the carrot
i was like i didn't think there was a
carrot so i was like how am i going to
be in a position where i can sell this
and
retain people in the business and then
my top bill the same day says i'm off
and leaves that day
so that was a that was a bad day i was
like
me
we'll wrap this up in like five minutes
i've just got like five final questions
is that okay yeah of course man okay so
um
wait i'll just i'll edit this bit out
just had some connection issues but
obviously tom you were sharing the
yeah you've obviously had some very bad
days like your top biller
leaving off to change the commission
structure so i guess
we were just keen to hear how you've
continued to
get better with that muscle of like
right today's a new day so i wasn't sure
what he was going to sort of say
to finish that i think i think the
muscle of today's a new day and also
like feeling it it's like you know
it gets easier you hear it time and time
again right and every time it gets a
little bit easier the rejection the nose
that the bad things are happening and
you just i don't think you take it
personally
come the end i think the first few times
you do take a personally go
you know it's it's it's you know it's
because of me or they're leaving me or
whatever it may be um to to now it's a
case of just like that's just what
happened
so just you know just you just have to
live with it
so i've got five final questions i'm
going to ask you but before i do i'm
interested to get your thoughts on this
question which is
like in your opinion what do you think
is the most important action or kpi that
contributes to recruiter success
um yeah i i think
it's i think recruitment is a contact
sport
so i think that the most important
action
is um is speaking to as many people for
um as possible as clients and candidates
as much as as much as you possibly can
getting on the phone and speaking to
people it's pretty old school right
but i think that that's that's the key
thing to that
speaking to canada speaking to clients
yes sir so final questions
first one yeah if you could
if you could change the industry what
would you improve
yeah um yeah i just
there's just the overall standards um i
think
recruiters get a quite a bad rep um
and we're probably tarnished with a
brush of um
you know the the guys that aren't so
good so
yeah for for me it's yeah just making
sure there's i don't know how you could
do that
um this is why i quite like the
uh the recessions because i think it's
almost like a bit of a a recruitment car
um i think at some points like every man
his dog is a recruiter
um and i think sometimes when it gets to
um
it gets to a recession um the the the
people that are faking recruitment
probably don't make it um and i think
just because of that the actual
industry standard goes up a little bit
but yeah that that would be
that would be how i don't know how i'd
improve it maybe a recruitment exam or
something of the light but yeah that's
just a better all-round um
a better all-round standard yeah um
what what book have you read that has
had the biggest impact on you
or something that you've listened to if
you're not a reader just what
what would you consume that's had a big
impact on you um
i'd i i recently listened to
the the king's book um
what books out it said the gypsy king's
book
um okay nice yeah
and in terms of books i'm probably more
of a listener than the reader
um but yeah i think more like
motivational
um support and and
you know how people battle through you
know some of the darker times and how
they come out
come out on top so that that yeah those
types of books are
yeah i fancy so this ties quite nicely
actually into a question that zeph sent
me
which is he wanted to know why you
didn't become a
full-time boxer after all the success
you had an amateur circuit
well yeah that's a very good question
very good question
[Laughter]
but um i did this boxing thing and
listen i've never done boxing in my life
um and it was a thing called zero to
hero
and it was like 40 people and they got
paired up together
um and they could they made me the
captain for that not because i was the
best boxer i was a part of [ __ ]
um but but again i was i was the person
i put my hand up first every time
they did something i was like right i'll
try that i'll stick myself out my
comfort zone
um but that was is that my about my
about reads one and
oh and uh
i love that um what
what did you spend your first biggest
commission paycheck on
um i actually it was actually like
three months into um into my time at a
time at oprah's i'd um
i had like a 60 000 pound month um
it was like it was incredible was it
just everything went my way
um and there's a couple of things i did
with that
one was there was a person that worked
at a previous company that said um
he said i'll never amount to anything
and i'll never i never i brought
the big paychecks in um
and so one of the first things i did
with that was
i sent him a i sent him an email so
hello his name was ben
hello ben how are you doing mate um and
he's like yeah
no problem how are you getting on i said
i said uh
and it's quite quite crude thing but i
said listen mate it's my 16
grand paycheck um
i was one of my friends my first act and
that and that filled me with like
so much like dagger but that film was
someone's joy being able to prove
someone wrong right
yeah yeah fair no thank you for sharing
that respect
with the page i actually actually
actually booked a honeymoon and paid for
my
pay for my wedding um with that paycheck
so yeah that was that was
good final one tom what
what's the uh what's the ultimate goal
for your recruitment career
i i don't know i again i i like i don't
know i'm like what i'm at the moment i'm
enjoying myself
i'm enjoying myself and it's going well
and
um and and i'm enjoying the ride so
ideally what where would i like to go i
i don't i don't really have a
have a clue but i'm i'll keep i'll keep
on the riding until i'm not having fun
right
um so where could i go
well i'd like to be in a position where
we have uh free from the ground and and
expand our manchester office to have an
office in
in london to build this office um
and in terms of like the end game
could i be in a position where i'd
become i could i could become hands off
and
start up a career in golf or i'm not
really not sure
we'll see we'll see where it takes me
but i don't really think too far ahead
and i think that can be dangerous
um at the moment i know where you know
where i am and i know i'm enjoying
myself so
yeah we'll see where it takes me i love
that tom it's been an absolute pleasure
thank you for being so
candid honest love your positive
attitude and really excited to see where
sort of amber go over the next couple of
years so thank you for uh
coming on and sharing the story thanks
so much mate appreciate your time